um
good morning everyone
welcome to the final
science technology and energy committee
meeting of the
we have quite a bit to do today it's
going to be a
unusual day and I'll explain that in
just a moment but before we do that I'd
like everybody to rise and join
representative John Mann as he leads us
and now I would like you all to remain
so that we can acknowledge
members of the committee who will be
retiring after this session and thank
them for their service
so first of all I'd like to recognize
the doyen of stne
representative Jackie Kelly Pitts
[Applause]
26 years of bipartisanship
Jackie says
Jackie's sense of humor has gotten us
through some tough times on this
committee and will miss her greatly and
we thank you Jackie for your service to
our state
next I'd like to recognize
John's many years of service on this
committee have been greatly appreciated
he's taught us all a lot about Energy
Efficiency made us understand just how
important it is
and while we may not may not always
agree on the best way to pay for it we
at least know how important Energy
Efficiency is so thank you John for your
years of service to our state we we
appreciate you and thank you for the
okay next I'd like to recognize
representative Lee oxenham
[Applause]
thank you Lee for your service to the
committee
I know that you believe passionately in
the cause of renewable energy and we
have learned a tremendous amount from
you your uh
debate
information was always informative and
helped us understand issues more
thoroughly and we appreciate all the
work that you've put in we appreciate
how you've served your
constituents over the course of your
term in the legislature so thank you
and finally we'd like to recognize
thank you Peter for your work as the
ranking member for ably leading your
caucus for providing lots of great
information during debates
and for doing a a great job supporting
your constituents in in Portsmouth well
miss you I understand maybe there's more
political work in your future we wish
you the best uh wherever that takes you
okay
so we're going to be passing judgment on
eight retained bills this morning
to refresh your memory there are two
things we can do with a retained bill at
this stage of the session
one is recommendable for future
legislation the other is do not
recommend the bill for future
legislation
so those are the decisions that we'll be
making today
now we have three out of the eight bills
that were heard by a subcommittee so for
those three bills we're going to go
straight to
an executive session
the other five bills were not heard by a
subcommittee so we're going to have a
brief work session on each of those
bills before we move into executive
session to make the final determination
now I mentioned earlier that today's
session was going to be a little bit
unusual
and here's the reason why
at 10 50
this morning we're going to take a break
from committee work we're not going to
recess the session we're just going to
take an extended break
and the reason for the break is that
there's going to be a news conference
downstairs in the lob lobby at 11
o'clock and
some of us on the committee
will be participating in that news
conference so we will take a break
from about 10 50 until about 11 30 to
participate in that news conference then
we will resemble reassemble in this room
at 11 30 to finish whatever work that we
haven't accomplished up to that point
if it should be the case that we finish
all eight bills before then
we will simply adjourn the meeting and
say goodbye to each other for the uh for
the session
for those of you who came in late we did
take a group picture right before the
session started uh I hope you were here
in time to get in in the picture if you
weren't we made attempt it again
afterwards but
that might be difficult with people
having to go downstairs
Etc et cetera but we'll see how that
works out
representative Kelly Pitts did you have
the news conference will be about the
do I know that I said we know that we do
actually oh okay
okay we do
all right so
uh
you can all enjoy the news conference
later if you so choose but let's get to
the work of the committee
I'd like to open a work session on House
Bill 213
and ask the committee if anyone has any
concerns any issues any comments they'd
like to make about House Bill 213 to
refresh your memory that was relative to
the elimination of useful thermal energy
from renewable energy classes
does anybody want to make a comment
about this bill
Representatives opsich
thank you Mr chairman
um yeah my comment would be I would
think that this is a this is a bill that
we should not recommend for approval
because as the chairman himself has said
next year will be the year of biomass
and I think this is directly related to
biomass
okay thank you uh representative
Harrington
yeah I would recommend for this uh
legislation on this because we've just
all been talking about the increase in
electric prices and this is simply a
buried tax in electric rates the
electric grade pay shouldn't be paying
for useful thermal energy we think
that's a good idea we ought to tax
something else where people can see it
we all talk about transparency if you
ask the Thousand electric rate payers in
New Hampshire I think maybe other than
the ones who are directly benefiting
from this through this subsidy probably
one or two of them would know that
they're paying for useful thermal energy
as part of their electric rates we need
to do whatever we can to lower electric
rates and we always should push for
transparency in government and not hide
taxes for some place where no one can
okay any further comment representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman
um well I I look at this bill and say
that uh it may have
um
it may have some uh use at some point
but I don't think this particular bill
as it is right now is ready uh to go
because we do have significant
disagreement about whether it is of
value to the rate payers and is of value
to how we're operating as far as the
energy portfolio that we're running
right now in New Hampshire we don't have
any information to indicate that this is
a good decision and I don't want to see
us making any more poor decisions around
thermal energy and its value to our
energy portfolio so I would be in favor
of letting this bill go if something
comes back in the next session that's a
different story but this particular bill
doesn't seem to have a
have appropriate vetting so that we know
that it would be useful
thank you representative Kelly Pitts
I'm going to preach for the last time I
this bill is dead
and and I've been saying that for two
committee meetings it's not it's not a
bill anymore
what has to happen if you want to move
it forward
and the committee recommends that and
that's all we're doing recommend or not
recommend and then it's up to the people
who are here next year to file new
legislation or not file new legislation
so I I want everybody to understand that
this bill
thank you I'll remind members to turn
your microphone off after you finish
speaking representative oxenham
uh thank you chair Vos for taking my
comment this bill is very much in the
tradition of the last six to ten years
of energy bills coming out of this
committee bills reviewed by this
committee it's all about trying to gut
the policies that we instituted to
assist renewable energy and to assist
Energy Efficiency which are the two
proven ways to reduce costs reduce rates
and reduce people's bills I had hoped
that after the recent Embrace of biomass
by the Republican majority that we had
seen and ended this kind of Bill and I
certainly thought this bill would have
been swept under the carpet at the
beginning of this meeting I'm delighted
that it was called out and then we
couldn't point to this as absolutely a
picture-perfect example of Republican
policy on energy and it's the reason we
have the highest rates the highest bills
um boring only Hawaii we need to be
investing money we have thrown away a
million and a half dollars of Reggie
money which was not invested which did
not decrease people's costs which did
not weatherize homes
and the RPS we have had to close down
our programs because there's no money
because wreck sweeping means we don't
have alternative compliance payments I
would like to see this bill recommended
for further action just to bring to
everyone's notice what kind of policies
have been put forward during this
session
thank you
okay thank you any further comment
seeing none I'm going to close the work
session on House Bill 213 and open an
executive session on House Bill 213 and
I recognize
representative Harrington I'd like to
make a motion Mr chairman
I would move that we recommend this bill
for further legislation
recognize representative Thomas second
it's been moved and seconded that we
recommend this bill for future
seeing none
I'll ask the clerk to call the roll on
the question of
recommend for future legislation on
House Bill 213.
but
the clerk is doing his uh due diligence
on paperwork so it'll take just a second
representative Thomas yes
representative Harrington yes
representative naughter yes
representative merner yes representative
votes yes representative yes
foreign
okay a representative cambrells yes
representative White
representative
yes representative white is he here
okay
uh representative lewicki yes
represents no representative Kelly Pitts
representative Mann yes
representative oxenham yeah
Representative Vincent is not here
per episode creature not here
represent Pimentel not here
uh representative partial oh
okay
and the chair
yes uh you skipped me did I skip who me
is there any member present who did not
Mr clerk what was the vote tally please
4-0
and
you know three three not present
okay thank you by a vote of fourteen to
four we're missing one there hold on one
two three
all right by a vote of fourteen to four
then
the committee votes to recommend this
bill for future legislation I'll close
the executive session on House Bill 213.
now I'd like to open a work session on
House Bill 1248 this is a bill relative
to replacement power for net metering
customer generators
and
ask the committee if anybody has any
comment on this legislation I'll just
refresh everyone's memory that this bill
sought to require
renewable energy generators who
are intermittent to acquire replacement
power for the periods of time when
they're not producing power of Their Own
but the bill provided no mechanism to do
that and had many other flaws and that's
why it was moved to interim study there
has been no new developments on
by the prime sponsor on how to fix the
Bill's flaws
does anybody else have any comments to
make representative samsich
well I would just I would just point out
that in most cases when you have a
renewable energy project uh the the
entities the businesses that engage in
this will require some type of
compensation or replacement anyway so I
don't think that that is that a bill is
needed for that it is already happening
now
okay any further comment representative
McGee thank you Mr chair yeah and just
to add on to that for folks who are
smaller generations and who are not
entered into those kind of pp
uh Arrangements uh
they basically are
adding uh Supply locally so that
additional energy doesn't have to be
brought into the supply from out of
state so they were always designed to be
an adder and not uh the same as you know
the firm energy that we require to be at
a higher rate so it it's a it's a plus
and I think this bill took us in the
wrong direction trying to say that it
needed to be something that it's not
intended to be so
that's all okay any further comment
thank you representative McGee seeing
none I'd like to close the work session
and open an executive session on House
Bill 1248 and I recognize representative
Platt
yes I move to not recommend
I recognize representative Thomas second
it's been moved and seconded that we not
recommend this bill for future
legislation is there any further comment
or discussion
I would just say in support of my motion
that uh
there's no way to enforce first of all
if we were to require replacement power
uh second there uh since they never got
a capacity payment there's no obligation
uh so those are the two killers right
there and if ISO New England if it grows
enough to be a problem ISO New England
will point it out and at some future
gate but right now that since they don't
counter Mis capacity that's all they
make that up through their
capacity Market with other resources
okay any further discussion who seconded
that sorry representative Thomas
seconded the motion
okay seeing none I'll ask the work clerk
to call the roll on the question of not
recommend for future legislation on
House Bill 1248. representative Thomas
yes representative Harrington yeah
representative naughter yes
representative Werner yes representative
Platt votes yes representative yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative yes represent yes
representative white not present
uh representative lewicki yes
representative samsish
yes representative Kelly Pitts
yes yes okay represent a man yes
representative oxenham yes
absent
representative McGee
uh yes representative McWilliams yes
represent Christian not present
uh representative not president it's
right there right there oh Pimentel
partial
representative partial yes I'm glad
you're here representative partial I'm
glad to be here thank you
the new pimental
okay 18 yes for not present oh the chair
okay thank you Mr Clark uh by a vote of
18 to nothing the committee adopts the
recommendation of not recommend for
future legislation so I'd like to see Mr
chair session do we have 22 members
we're
21.22. okay thank you yes
close the executive session on 12 48 and
open a work session on HB 1635.
this bill was relative to the purchase
of the output of limited electrical
energy producers and including
qualifying storage systems
we sent this bill to interim study as
you'll all recall because it was super
seated by a Senate bill Senate Bill 321
which passed out of this committee with
an amendment was concurred by the the
Senate and was eventually signed by the
governor
and representative McGee who originally
filed this bill agreed that it was no
longer necessary having been superseded
by
uh Senate Bill 321
is there any further discussion that we
need to have on this particular
piece of legislation proposed
legislation
seeing now I'll close the work session
and open a executive session on House
Bill 1635
and I recognize representative berezny
for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move that we'd
not recommend 1635 for further
legislation
chair recognizes representative Thomas
second it's been moved and seconded that
we not recommend HB 1635 for future
legislation
and I'd like to know if there's any
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of not
recommended for future legislation on HB
1635 representative
Thomas yes representative Harrington yes
representative yes
representative murder yes representative
uh plattvos yes representative yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative yes representative
closure yes representative white not
president
yes
representative sunfish
representative Kelly Pitts represent a
man yes represent rocks on him
representative Vince is not president
representative McGee yes representative
McWilliams yes represent creature
not president representative Pimentel
not present representative partial yes
okay that would make it 18 of the chair
yes
that would make it 18-0 and four not
present
okay by a vote of 18 to nothing the
committee recommends not recommended for
future legislation on HB 1635 I'll close
that public hearing
or uh executive session rather
and the next bill on our list is HB 1644
and because there was a subcommittee on
this particular bill there's no need for
any a work session so I'm going to open
an executive session on HB 1644 and
the motion is to the motion is for
further legislative action whatever that
might be somebody speak to my motion
yes after we get a second uh
representative Platt is recognized oh
second it's been moved and seconded to
recommend right it's been moved in
second and that we recommend for future
legislation House Bill 1644 and
representative Thomas is recognized to
speak to the motion yes uh during our
work session it was um uh decided that
uh
something addition should be done on
this subject matter and what came to
light were perhaps education might be
needed for people on the pros and cons
of RF radiation and also what came to
light was perhaps a lack of
understanding of what local communities
can do in terms of the tower placements
so because of this additional
information that came forward and really
not for anything else we we decided that
perhaps there's room for further
legislative action to that might want to
cover those particular subjects and
that's that was the emphasis and the
basis for the recommendation for further
legislative action there was uh no other
question for you representative Thomas
what was the subcommittee vote on that
legislation subcommittee vote I believe
was
four to one
uh representative white was not present
and uh so it was
five to one excuse me five to one
because uh representative bresney was
part of our committee so it was five to
one
okay is there any further discussion on
this piece of legislation representative
oxenham
thank you very much for taking this
question uh clarification you mentioned
the um
lack of understanding of what local
communities can do in terms of citing
could you share with us what your
subcommittee may have discovered about
this that we did not hear in the
original public hearing
uh
basically
we learned that in terms of Aesthetics
or other
um
uh or in terms of um safety in terms of
if a tower were to fall down and hit a
particularly critical item like a school
uh that the towns would have reason to
decide where a tower could be placed
along those lines and there seemed to be
a lack of understanding that some towns
uh
recognize that fact and so we we felt
that additional information and
education would be needed in case towns
wanted to take those things in into
consideration also it was brought up by
representative Kelly Pitts that uh there
was a lot of Education or a lot of
misunderstanding that may not be out
there to the local public and perhaps
some entity from the state agency
perhaps something like Department of
energy we don't know might be able to
put out some education for people to
better understand what is or isn't
safe in involving RF radiation
those things came to light during the
the work session and so for those
reasons we felt that some type of
legislative action might be warranted in
the future so that's why we we voted
that way thank you representative Callie
Pitts
but I think
I think that what
I'm not discussing here or what we need
to stick to is what we are doing here
and not the content and and that sort of
thing I think I would I would ask the
chair to review just the caption of what
the bill is because I don't know if this
is being filmed or not because a lot of
people don't know what 1644 is
so I would just say that's what it is
but ours is not to go through the the
details ours is to just do we think we
okay thank you and I apologize for not
reading the title of the bill the bill
is relative to the placement of
telecommunication antenna and
establishing a registry for residents
who are experiencing biological symptoms
from Wireless radiation exposure is
there any further discussion from
representative sausage
thank you thank you Mr chair uh
representative Thomas I just wanted to
ask in regard to the the study committee
uh was there any talk about uh the
impact of these towers on real estate
values I know this is happening in
various places in the country where uh
when these towers are very close to
residential areas uh there there is a
genuine impact on real estate values was
there any discussion about that in the
study committee not directly no
um the discussion was primarily around
safety or fire hazards on Towers if they
were too close some particular critical
facility if they were to fall or catch
fire it could present some type of a
safety hazard that way but nothing about
property values during that discussion
representative nodder
thank you Mr chairman I was the one no
vote on the subcommittee because I have
no doubt that legislation is going to be
filed regardless of the recommendation
of the committee so I didn't feel it was
necessary to have it a unanimous vote
thank you representative partial may I
call the vote
um well I wouldn't want to just stifle
debate but if there are no other folks
who want to uh
you want to speak yes let's call the
boat so I'll ask the clerk to call the
role on the recommendation that we
recommend this bill for future
legislation
representative Harrington yes
Representative naughter no
representative merner yes
representative I have to explain this I
was asked to second the motion so I did
Representative no
representative Bernardi yes
representative cambrell's
yes
representative yes
representative White
not here
uh representative lewicki yes
purpose of some such yes
representative Kelly Pitts
yes
representative Mann
representative oxenham
Representative Vincent not here
representative McGee yes representative
Williams yes representative creature
absent representative absent
uh representative partial yes okay I in
okay
for absent so the difference ought to be
three
and let's see if that's true one two
three yes so uh 15 yes three no and four
absent
okay by a vote of fifteen to three the
committee
passes the recommendation of recommend
for future legislation
I'll close the public hearing of the
executive session rather on HB 1644 and
we will now move to a work session on
Senate Bill
113. does anyone have any comments to
make on Senate Bill 113 it was relative
to the alternative compliance payments
for renewable energy obligations not met
through the purchase of renewable energy
credits it was submitted to the
committee by Senator Bradley in the
first year of our session and we put it
on or we judged it to be worthy of
interim study
uh since that time Senator Bradley has
informed us that he thinks that this
bill should not go forward
does anybody have any further comment on
it
representative flat though I don't
object to uniformity I did object to the
highest possible level
but to make it uniform
okay
great
seeing that I'll ask the clerk to call
the uh
I'll close the work session rather and
open a executive session on Senate Bill
113 and I'll recognize representative
cambrils yes thank you Mr chair
um I would like to make a motion to not
recommend any further legislation on
this bill
representative Thomas second has been
moved and seconded that we not recommend
any future legislation on Senate Bill
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of not
recommend for future legislation on
um representative Thomas
yes
representative uh Harrington yes
representative Mater yes representative
merner yes representative Platt yes OTS
remember origini yes
represent Bernardi yes representative
cambrells yes represent yes
representative White
not present representative lewicki yes
representative
yes representative Kelly Pitts
yes
representative Mann yes representative
oxeno
Representative Vincent not present
representative McGee yes representative
McWilliams
no
representative creature
not present representative Pimentel not
present
represent partial
not present okay
well 17.
one and four absent
okay by a vote of Seventeen to one
second five absence so that's
16 18. huh sixteen to one sixteen to one
okay
by about a sixteen to one the committee
to be suitable for not recommending for
future legislation so I'll close the
executive session on Senate bill
113.
the next bill on the list is Senate Bill
259 it did have a subcommittee so we're
going to go directly to Executive
session on Senate bill 259.
and the chair recognizes representative
thank you Mr chair uh uh subcommittee
recommendation was to recommend for
further
okay the subcommittee recommended
recommend for future legislation
representative Thomas that's the motion
second
representative Thomas seconds the motion
so representative Bernardi as the
committee subcommittee chair could you
give us a synopsis of what the
subcommittee's thinking was please
this uh thank you Mr chairman uh so
there was considerable discussion about
what a municipal host uh meant and and
the definitions that were to be added by
this uh Senate bill
um
key among them were
quasi-public entities uh
public housing authorities or housing
authorities and the peas Development
Authority
um
so the discussion went broader than that
indicating that there there was
opportunity here to address some of the
issues associated with Municipal
boundaries not and and utility
boundaries not being coincident and and
therefore this bill could correct that
potentially but the bill is written
doesn't correct that so we had
a a vote of two to one
um in favor of
A continuing on with the legislation
but to be amended to address these uh
issues that are not in the bill and and
um so I was the one member who said no
the bill is currently written does not
address that so I voted no
thank you any future further discussion
thank you very much Mr chair yes as one
of the people that voted for the
recommendation to move forward that was
to bring it to the attention of this
body understanding as
representative Kelly Pitts has told us
repeatedly that we're not going to
change the bill today but to go on to
the record as saying this is a bill
where there is a demonstrated need for
action and I strongly encourage someone
on the committee and I think I have a
candidate to to file a bill at the next
legislative window but I I passed out
once again the the color picture this is
a problem the municipal Association is
now involved they will be lobbying in
favor of action to rectify this problem
because ninety percent of the towns in
our state cannot use this legislation
because their their population is too
small their load is too small and or as
is the case for the town that I
principally represent they have three
utilities for a town of 3 400 people and
coming up with with the load of one
megawatt is uh you know you're not going
to be able to find a cost-efficient way
to to go forward so just just wanted to
put that in the record that as our chair
said in May this is a problem and it
needs to be fixed and I strongly
encourage everyone to support the bill
when it comes to you next year thank you
thank you any further discussion on
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the recommendation that we
recommend for future legislation Senate
Bill 259. representative Thomas yes
representative Harrington
no
Representative naughter no
representative Werner no representative
votes no
Representative no
representative Bernardi no
representative Campbell's no
representative closure no
representative White
not present
Representative lewicki no
perhaps of Cali yes
representative Mann yes representative
oxenham
Representative Vincent not present
representative McGee yes representative
McWilliams yes representative creature
absent representative Pimentel accent
absent uh and representative partial is
absent still
okay
in the chair
I vote no
okay one two three one two three four
one two three four five six seven eight
through camera's
[Music]
9 10
uh no
and five absent
seventy
okay by a vote of seven yes seven yes
ten no the recommendation of the
subcommittee is defeated and the chair
recognizes representative Bernardi for a
motion
thank you Mr chair I make a motion to
not recommend future legislation this is
future legislation
representative
second
it's been moved and seconded that we
judge Senate Bill 259 to be not
recommended for future legislation
questions Mr chair
if we if we voted seven to ten against
recommending do we have to go to not
recommend
don't we have to pass emotion
is that the committee consensus yes
all right well we will dismiss my motion
all right we're Consulting with an
[Music]
huh
so the official uh the the expert
recommendation is we do have to vote on
a motion to not recommend okay we can't
just turn down emotion we have to vote
positively on a motion
so
we just we just had an opinion from
um
committee staff so
I'm going to ask the clerk to call the
role on the question of not recommended
for future legislation motion has to be
oh you withdrew it I didn't hear you do
that I agree I thank you Mr chairman I
will remake the motion to not recommend
for future legislation
a second representative Thomas seconds
the motion okay so now we can go forward
please call the roll Mr clerk yeah but
that will take me a moment because this
is catching me all by surprise okay
people
for me it's a waste of time
um
okay
I believe Masons would say that if a
motion is defeated then you have to make
a new motion
to State your position so
I think we're doing the right thing here
and as soon as the clerk is ready we're
going to do it I'm emptying the last
vote tally
so I can redo it
foreign
not recommending a representative Thomas
yes professor of Harrington yes
representative yes representative yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative Campbells yes
representative closure yes
representative white and I present
representative lewicki yes represent no
representative Kelly no represent mayor
no representative oxenham
Representative Vincent not president
uh representative McGee no
representative McWilliams no
representative Christian not present
representative Pimentel not president
and representative partial not president
is that correct okay so in the chair
votes yes okay one
two three four
sign through cameras
11.
two three
four five six five it's eleven six five
that's correct
the vote is eleven four uh six opposed
okay by a vote of eleven to six the
committee adopts the recommendation that
we not recommend this bill for future
legislation so I'll close the executive
session on Senate bill 259.
now we are going to take a break
until 11 30 we have two bills to finish
at 11 30. I suspect that
we will be able to finish those by noon
time which would be
a welcome finish to our
two-year session so I will see you all
back here at 11 30 and thank you for
your hard work so far this morning we'll
get this done get it completed in just a
little while
bye
I'm sorry
okay
[Music]
was the waves
much
those
foreign
please take your seats so that we can
okay while we're waiting for the
stragglers to return to the committee
room here
I would like to open a work session on
Senate bill 264.
which is a bill relative to certain
references to the Department of energy
and transferring authority over the
low-income electric electricity
assistance program to the Department of
energy
and I would remind members that when we
had the public hearing on this bill the
department of energy and the Public
Utilities Commission were in
disagreement about
uh the authority over the low-income
electricity assistance program
and the transfer to the Department of
energy was uh the department of energy
withdrew its request for the transfer of
that Authority so this bill was sent to
interim study because of that and
um
it would appear that the the question is
moot at this point is there any
discussion on this uh Mr chairman Bill
64 264. representative Harrington thank
you uh I might just say since we have a
representative of the Department of
energy here would it be appropriate to
ask him what their present position is
oh absolutely
well sorry Griffin but I guess you're on
the hook so what is the Department of
Energy's current position on Senate bill
264.
and we appreciate you being here and
being willing to
uh thank you Mr chairman for the record
Griffin Roberge State energy program
manager with the Department of energy
I believe the department just wanted to
confer with the puc a little bit more on
the programmatic structure of this
change before moving forward with it
additionally there are also some
language changes as I think you might
all recall from this I think you should
say on veto day with House Bill 1223
there was some additional language in
there that would restrict the puc from
making any modification to the SBC to uh
for the electric assistance program as
you recall that bill put an additional
seven million dollars into the electric
assistance program to shore it up so I
think at this point the department of
puc would like further discussion on
this bill before moving forward
okay thank you
any further discussion on Senate bill or
actually before we do that any further
questions from Mr robarge from the
committee representative Kelly Pitts I
have a question a real question when do
you expect that some of this money will
start flowing
um I'm assuming that and maybe I
shouldn't assume that rules have to be
developed and uh thank you for the
question I guess a question back to you
are you talking regarding the electric
assistance program or all the various
programs that were under HP 2023 various
programs various programs so uh the
electric assistance program to the best
of my knowledge is something that's been
continually going
um consumers residents can apply to
their Community Action Program and
obviously have to meet eligibility
standards to access that funding the
additional 7 million into that program
it's just meant to shore it up because
we anticipate increased demand in terms
of the other one-time benefits the 200
one-time electric benefit and the 450
dollar fuel assistance benefit I believe
to the best of my knowledge that those
contracts with the cap agencies were
recently approved at governor and
Council I imagine the program will
likely be underway soon I just would be
hesitant to give a specific timeline or
anything like that but I know the I know
there's certainly an urgency to get
those up and running sooner rather than
later
follow up
will uh gas be included natural gas be
included in those programs
I
I'd have to look back on the bill
um I can't give you a definitive answer
but if you if it's all right with a
community I can follow it by email if
that's all right the bill was fuel
neutral okay all right even wood would
be covered
okay any further questions for Mr
Roberts
seeing none I thank you for being
available this uh morning I think it's
still morning
and now I would ask the committee if
there is any further discussion on this
bill
seeing none I'm going to close the work
session on Senate Bill 264 and open an
executive session on the Senate Bill 264
and record in the eyes representative
nodder
I load I make a motion that we not
recommend further legislation
representative Thomas second
it's been moved and seconded that we not
recommend for future legislation Senate
seeing none I would ask the clerk to
call the role on the recommendation that
we not recommend for future legislation
representative Thomas yes
representative Arrington yes
representative otter yes representative
Mariner yes representative plattvotes
yes representative yes represent
Bernardi yes representative Cambridge
yes represent yes representative white
not here
representative lewicki yes
Representative samsich no
representative Kelly Pitts
representative Mann not voting I wasn't
here to hear the discussion okay
Representative Vincent not present
represent McGee
we're not present okay
representative McWilliams no
representative creature still not
present represent Prem Mattel still not
president president representative
partial well okay
three
one two
or no
six six that's what I'm off by one
somewhere
representative McGee is still being uh
excuse yes is still being interviewed
from the press conference okay but
should I just put her down is not
present
okay
wow
who
so representative Mann you were here
when the question was put and even
though you did not hear the discussion
there's some question about whether you
whether you need to vote uh on the
question
we've asked the clerk okay and we're
we're waiting for an answer I'll vote no
okay representative Mann votes no
well
yes five no
and uh five not present
okay by a vote of 12 to 5 the committee
adopts the recommendation of not
recommended for future legislation on
Senate bill 264. so we'll close the
executive session on Senate bill 264.
and go to the final bill of the day and
this bill was referred to a subcommittee
so we do not have to have a work session
on it now we'll go straight to an
executive session on Senate Bill 269 and
I'm sorry I will read the title of the
bill Senate Bill 269 establishing a
commission to study energy saving
weatherization programs
representative murder
yes we had a meeting on Tuesday on this
work session on this bill in a chemo
um
five to one vote not to recommend for uh
for the legislation
that's so that is your emotion and
that's my motion that's recommended
representative Thomas second
moved and seconded that we judge Senate
Bill 269 to be not recommended for
future legislation is there any
discussion representative Mann
please use your microphone
thank you
um what's my option to can I discuss
anything about the bill or anything
about that what is it
yes you can you can you can discuss the
committee recommendation was five to one
not to recommend right but we don't have
to follow them but we're all going to
vote and we don't have to vote yay on
that we can vote nay thank you okay
um well my discussion would be
um I hope it's more more
coherent then
Tuesdays but anyway
um
the bill has an awful lot of content
about Energy Efficiency and uh however
Energy Efficiency is a wide wide wide
subject
and it's not well understood
um one of the areas that's got the
biggest Financial impact to the state is
Energy Efficiency of buildings we call
it building Energy Efficiency and what
happens with that is
um you know it's about where the
building is able to resist winter cold
and summer heat essentially without
spending excess of energy
so there's a big impact with that and um
one of the impacts one of the pieces of
that is that buildings are heated and
there's a great deal of fossil energy
spent in heating buildings it's not just
electrical energy that we're talking
about saving so if you can reduce the
amount of air conditioning or heating or
building needs you're saving both
electricity and
CO2 generation but that's different
subject and the cost for fuel
and there's other various things first
of all um it seems that a long-term
Energy Efficiency program if we
scheduled one to do Energy Efficiency
for buildings
could produce uh an accelerating would
produce an accelerating
return on investment and the reason for
that is that every building that you
insulate will stay insulated for the
rest of it's live until it burns down or
something so
those all build up and if you graph it
out the return on investment
goes up with a square function in other
words it accelerates so over time you
get to the point where the previously
done Energy Efficiency work saves enough
money for the economy for the economy to
keep spending it on More Energy
Efficiency for to finish the job with
all the other buildings so it's a really
major major subject area the financing
the benefits how it has to be done the
quality control
you know what a focus is and so on that
really needs work and
um so I highly recommend that this um
that this bill that we passed this um
I recommend this bill for further study
because it is a very important and
useful Bill thank you although I would
perfectly well admit it's as written it
needs a lot of amendment thank you
okay thank you uh further discussion
I voted against this bill coming through
and I I would do it again we've been
doing Energy Efficiency
for as long as I can remember we started
out with plastic and tape we've moved to
Total insulation we've done light bulbs
we've been working on this forever
however my feeling on this bill was we
don't need another commission
we studied it to death we know what we
need to do
and instead of doing this we need to
just do it and I do believe that
there are members of this Legend the
next legislature who will introduce
legislation to do just that thank you
thank you further discussion
representative samsich
thank you Mr chair
um well I greatly respect my colleague
representative Mann's comments about
Energy Efficiency
I also agree with representative Kelly
Pitts that
um
that a commission like this is totally
unnecessary we already know that
weatherization works we know why it
works a low-income residents have
already been receiving weatherization
Energy Efficiency programs it has been
demonstrated to work so the only way I
would ever vote for a commission like
this is if itself through its
discussions and hot air could generate
some energy on its own otherwise I think
it's a waste of time and money
seeing none uh representative Mann I'll
well we do appreciate the education
you've given us about Energy Efficiency
and building rather whetherization but
this is a bill that's mostly about a
commission so keep that right and I
think uh if you notices all the
stakeholders are involved
the governor the
all the utilities
it's just a wide range of people and
they all have different perspectives the
utilities for example have been getting
decent money to help with Energy
Efficiency by uh buying new
refrigerators for
you know low-income customers
now that saves a little electricity but
it's insignificant and that money might
better be spent
weatherizing three or four little houses
so there's a lot to do in that
commission this is a major major subject
area very poorly understood it's almost
laughable we talk about Energy
Efficiency as if we all knew all about
I'm the only person in this committee
that has done any analysis mathematical
analysis of what the well how the thing
goes how it's done
I've been involved in several Energy
Efficiency projects my house cannot be
made more Energy Efficiency it was
designed
I even have
a cold roof separating it from the real
roof because if we had our shingles on
an insulated roof that we have
the sun would curl them up and they'd
rot away from the Heat
so there's a lot to know about this and
I I so tried to make that clear
yesterday but I certainly
I'm sounding more like an old man but um
uh so I I really think a commission uh
that is a serious commission could
really dig into this and hopefully you'd
have members on it that had a very
strong point of view so we could have
some really solid discussions thank you
I'll I'll end it there I won't say
another word
okay thank you I'd also remind the
committee members that the Energy
Efficiency landscape is going to change
fairly significantly going forward
because the so-called inflation
reduction Act
uh sends a lot of money to the states to
do Energy Efficiency and New Hampshire
is in line to get tens of millions of
new dollars for Energy Efficiency so
the distribution and expenditure of that
money is going to be of significant
discussion and concern over the next uh
several years
see no further discussion on the
question I would like to ask the clerk
to call the roll on the question of not
recommendation not recommended for
future legislation on Senate bill 269.
representative Thomas
yes representative Harrington yes
purpose of an otter yes representative
merner yes representative plattvotes yes
representative
yes representative Bernardi yes
representative Campbell's yes represent
yes representative White's still not
present representative lewicki yes
representative samsich yes
representative Kelly Pitts
representative men no
representative oxygen oxygen
per episode of Vince is not present
representative McGee no
representative McWilliams no
represent creation not present represent
Pimentel not president
represent partial take a luxury no okay
yeah uh and the chair
yes
yeah
uh 14 uh forward not recommending four
against and four not present
okay thank you Mr clerk so buy a vote of
fourteen to four
the committee votes to not recommend for
please uh
if you unless you've been granted the
floor
um let's keep the chatter down
so that concludes our work for the
2021-2022 legislative session
and I'd like to congratulate everybody
on this committee for
your diligence in studying the bills
that have presented been presented to us
trying to understand them and bringing
your best judgment to bear on the fate
of those bills I know you've all worked
hard
you've all done your best to represent
what you believe to be the beliefs of
your constituents and I'm very grateful
that we've had a committee that operated
smoothly that while we've had
disagreements there have been no
fights no uh ugliness we've all treated
each other with the respect that we all
deserve and I'm grateful for that and I
commend you all for conducting
representative Harrington yeah just for
a moment of personal privilege I just
wanted to mention
um this committee whoever comes back on
it is never going to be the same as far
as I'm concerned I was first served here
in 2002 and uh Jackie was on there at
that time and I just got envisioned the
committee without her she lost into
primary I know the committee and the
house of New Hampshire House of
Representatives a better place with her
in it and we'll miss you a lot Jackie
thank you representative Harrington and
I'll Echo those comments by saying that
we will miss you representative Kelly
Pitts
so without further Ado we actually
completed uh
representative oxenham as a comment I'd
just like to
Express the appreciation of the members
of the committee for the work of the
chair the vice chair and particularly
the clerk who came back from a serious
illness to supply very needed services
for this committee but again the the
fact that the fights never degenerated
into fist fights the fact that there was
no name calling and we could uh you know
go out and have a a meal together at the
end all testified to your ability to
bridge differences and and I'd just like
to express the appreciation for your
your role here well thank you you're
very kind and generous to say that and I
appreciate it very much
representative Callie Pitts would like
to make a call like short and sweet the
Reader's Digest version I want to thank
you all for tolerating me for 26 years
you have gotten a reprieve thank you
representative Thomas yes thank you I
just want to add for the record
what we've gone through in these last
two years here is nothing short of his
historic and two years in so many ways
could feel like 10 years because the of
where we were two years ago to where we
are now is like night and day and if you
can think back of what we went through
starting two years ago so many things
happened so many things uh changed so
many historic events happened and I
think anyone that is was here present
who is not coming back and those that
are coming back need to understand this
was truly a historic period in time for
being a legislator in the state of New
Hampshire and uh I like to my thanks to
everybody who cooperated leadership
minority party the whole nine yards this
has truly been a whirlwind of just a
mixed bag of a lot of things that we had
to do to get the job done thank you
thank you
seeing none
this committee is adjourned for the